and among this fascinating group of
texts there is also the mysterious
Gospel of Phillip a text which can be
hard to categorize but which has become
famous worldwide by showing up in pop
culture such as in The DaVinci Code its
Fame primarily stems from a certain
juicy section or quote which we will get
to later um it's called a gospel but
it's not a gospel in the traditional
sense as we know the gospels from the
New Testament in that it is not a an
account of the life of Jesus and his
teachings in that way at all uh neither
is it like the Gospel of Thomas which is
just a collection of sayings by Jesus
instead the gospel of philli is like
just a collection of paragraphs and and
short sections about various different
topics um sometimes the this gospel can
feel kind of disjointed